all'inizio
ho preso uno stuzzicadenti e lo spezzato
non so se vi è mai capitato di notare
che quando spezziamo un legno c'è sempre
una parte che cede e una parte che
resiste e come se una linea cambiasse
bruscamente il suo corso senza però
arrestarsi fa angolo ma continua a
essere una linea non diventano due linee
se ci spezziamo un osso non abbiamo due
ossa non possiamo metterlo nella terra
come fosse la talea di una rosa e
sperare che i germogli
in primavera
possiamo solo sperare di non esser cielo
rotto troppo di poterlo ricomporre e che
la frattura si rinsaldi
le linee
geometriche invece godono di questa
salute istantanea si spezzano sulla
carta e subito sono pronte a correre in
un'altra direzione
fresca come una rosa
diciamo pure che
le linee in geometria si spezzano che è
un piacere che verrebbe quasi voglia di
cambiare la parola per rispetto verso
il dolore di tutto quello che si spezza
che perde la sua integrità e resta
ancora attaccato a se stesso
nello spezzarsi
qualcosa di chiuso si apre suo malgrado
quando un legno si apre spezzandosi e la
sua stessa struttura che cede e l'intima
alleanza delle sue fibre che viene meno
che si scompone no che si disallinea il
tronco di un albero è fatto per non
rompersi
crescendo come vedete poi incurvarsi è
elastico si incurva negoziando nel tempo
con il vento che spinge di lato la sua
naturale tendenza a muoversi verso
l'alto la sua spinta alla verticalità
quando si rompe fa un rumore tipico fa
crac
troppa neve su un ramo
è questione di istanti comincia prima a
scricchiolare
se ci sei sotto non è neanche detto che
tu abbia il tempo di accorgersi di
quello che sta succedendo dopodiché
spezzandosi cade
ecco
adesso abbiamo cominciato a dare un
corpo a questa
linea priva di dimensione della
geometria
che può spezzarsi sulla carta può
ammirare in angoli improbabili e poi
chiudersi
a formare quel meraviglioso primo
poligono che è triangolo figura così
equilibrata
davanti a questo triangolo a questa
linea spezzata chiusa
possiamo percepire invece tutta la
tensione
tutto lo sforzo tutta la concretezza che
c'è dentro alla definizione
di linea spezzata chiusa la definizione
del triangolo in geometria possiamo
percepire
tutta la fatica e le difficoltà del
semplificare
possiamo percepire tutto
quell immenso travaglio che c'è voluto
per arrivare
a quell'ente mirabilmente disossato che
è la linea priva di dimensione
volendo spezzare una linea
ho finito per scegliere quelle linee
naturali che sono i tronchi degli alberi
da scultore volevo restituire un corpo a
questa idea non potendo accontentarmi di
tracciare con la matita sulla carta una
linea come suggeriscono i libri di
geometria
perché in scultura le idee sono corpi
la forma è sempre
incarnata la forma è sempre fatta di
qualche cosa
e
spesso si parla di forma di materia ma
in scultura voler dissociare la forma
dalla materia in cui quella forma accade
equivale a voler dissociare l'opera da
se stessa ai possibile
in scultura
anzi direi ogni scultura è un essere che
nasce dall'unione tra un uomo e un pezzo
di mondo
qualcosa che avrà
un po del padre è un po della madre
la materia è un qualcosa in più che la
renderà se stessa
ogni scultura
mi appare come un punto d'incontro
bastardo tra noi e il mondo qualcosa che
però testimonia della profonda parentela
che c'è tra l'uomo e tutte le cose un
uomo ha visto un tronco che galleggiava
sulla superficie del mare oppure ha
visto un tronco
trascinato dalla corrente del di un
fiume in piena e ha visto che non
affondava
questo è l'incipit di ogni navigazione
dalla canoa
alla portaerei
un uomo poi ha visto un tronco caduto
perpendicolare trasversalmente al corso
di un torrente al corso di un fiume
finalmente
ha intravisto la possibilità
in questo
piccolo trauma naturale
di poter passare oltre il fiume restando
nei fuori da qui
ogni altro ponte
sempre con questa sua
chiaroveggenza
l'uomo ha visto negli alberi i pilastri
e le colonne tutte quelle che ci sono
attorno tutte quelle che ci sono a
vicenza tutte le colonne del palladio
non
ha visto negli alberi le colonne e
pilastri per poter erigere i suoi
palazzi verticali ancora più in alto ma
sempre verso il sole chissà perché uno
strano foto tropismo
l'immaginazione è come un seme
universale
che può fecondare ogni cosa
al di là delle barriere di specie
perché quei semi degli alberi che
abbiamo visto prima non contenevano
quelle potenzialità se l'immaginazione
non ne avesse astratto delle
caratteristiche che pure possedevano
trasformando delle casualità in
opportunità straordinaria questa è
l'immaginazione questo è il suo potere
di inseminare di possibilità ulteriori
le cose di in gravi darle letteralmente
con i suoi sogni
e allo stesso tempo l'immaginazione è
uno sguardo che viene fecondato da tutto
senza distinzione
quindi direi che
che l'immaginazione
è una femmina grazie